STEVE: YOUNGKIN'S VICTORY SHOWED
THE SCHOOLS ON THE TOP ISSUES
FOR VOTERS PARENTS HAD ENOUGH OF
THE TOTALLY UNJUSTIFIED SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND IDEOLOGICAL
BRAINWASHING DRIVEN BY THE
TEACHERS UNION.
THEY ARE DEMANDING MORE FROM
CHANGE.
THE BIGGEST CHANGE OF ALL COULD
BE ON ITS WAY IN MY HOME STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANKS TO A NEW CROSS PARTY
MOVEMENT LED BY OUR NEXT GUEST,
THE BIGGEST AND BOLDEST
PRO-CHOICE INITIATIVE AMERICA
HAS EVER SEEN ON THE BALLOT IN
2022.
I'M DELIGHTED TO WELCOME SOMEONE
YOU KNOW AS FORMER ACTING
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE ALSO THE FOUNDER OF
FIXED CALIFORNIA AND GLORIA WHO
IS A DEMOCRAT MAJORITY LEADER IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
ALONG WITH CO-CHAIR ON FIXED
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE CHOICE
BONDING.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
GLORIA KICK US OFF WHAT WE HAVE
PLANNED FOR NEXT YEAR.
>> I'M ECSTATIC TO BE ABLE TO
CO-CHAIR THIS WITH GLORIA.
GLORIA IS A CHAMPION, PROUD
DEMOCRAT AND SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS CALIFORNIA IS
ACCEPTABLE TO HAVE THE KIDS
AVERAGE PARENTS BE THE ONE TO
ONLY GET TO PICK THE SCHOOL.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH
OF KIDS WHO HAVE TO GO TO CRAPPY
SCHOOLS ON THE STREET.
AMERICA IS ABOUT COMPETITION.
WHAT WERE DOING PUTTING A BALLOT
INITIATIVE TO THE VOTE NEXT YEAR
END THE 2022 ELECTION IN
CALIFORNIA ASKING CALIFORNIANS
DO YOU WANT TO OPEN THE WAY WE
FUND EDUCATION AND HAVE THE
MONEY FOLLOW THE STUDENT WE
THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME.
>> IT'S TELLING A REAL SCHOOL
CHOICE.
AND TALK TO SCHOOLS HERE THERE
IS A WHOLE SYSTEM CHANGING.
I'M HAPPY TO WELCOME YOU.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHAT WAS IT
THAT PERSUADED YOU TO TEAM UP
WITH RICK BEHIND THE GREAT
INITIATIVE.
>> FIRST OF ALL I HAD THE
GREATEST REGARD AND RESPECT FOR
RICK.
EDUCATION IS MY PASSION WHEN I
WAS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE I OVERSAW EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IN A CELL FIRSTHAND
HOW CALIFORNIA SPENT ALMOST HALF
OF OUR BUDGET EVERY YEAR TO FUND
THE SYSTEM.
NOT STUDENTS BUT A SYSTEM THAT
CONSISTENTLY FAILED STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS INITIATIVE SAID NO MORE
FUNDING A BLACKHOLE OF EDUCATION
WE ARE GOING TO FUND DIRECTLY
PARENTS, STUDENTS SO PARENTS CAN
CHOOSE THE BEST SCHOOL CHOICE
FOR THEM.
THAT IS MY COMMITMENT.
STEVE: I'VE GOT TO ASK YOU I AM
ALL FOR IT I'VE LONG ARGUED FOR.
THE TEACHERS UNIONS ARE AGAINST
IT BECAUSE IT TAKES THE POWER
AWAY FROM THEM AND PUT IN THE
HANDS OF THE PARENTS.
MOST DEMOCRATS ARE COMPLETELY
BOW DOWN BEFORE THE TEACHERS
UNION.
YOU'VE TAKEN THE STAND.
WHY IS THAT HOW IS OFTEN
PERSONALLY.
>> UNDOUBTEDLY THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IS THE MOST
POWERFUL POLITICAL FORCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
MORE POWERFUL THAN OIL, TOBACCO
AND PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES.
PERIOD TO SCARE SACRAMENTO
LEGISLATURES AWAY FROM DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
THAT'S WHY THIS INITIATIVE IS SO
IMPORTANT AS YOU POINTED OUT WE
STARTED TALKING WE HAVE SEEN
PARENTS IN ACTION THEY ARE
SAYING ENOUGH WERE TIRED WE WANT
TO PUT OUR KIDS FIRST AND THAT'S
WHY WE BELIEVE EDUCATION SAVINGS
ACCOUNT WILL REGISTER WITH
PARENTS TO GIVE US SCHOOL
CHOICE.
STEVE: IS TAKING ALL THE MONEY
THAT THE STATE SPENT IF THIS
GOES THROUGH AND ALL OF IT, NOT
JUST A LITTLE BIT, ALL OF IT.
THE PARENTS GET TO DECIDE.
THIS WILL HAVE NATIONAL
APPLICATIONS.
KIM PEOPLE WATCHING YOU WHO
DON'T LIVE IN CALIFORNIA, CAN
THEY SUPPORT THIS, TALK ABOUT
THE NATIONAL ASPECT OF THIS.
IT'S A REALLY BIG CHANGE THEIR
APPROVING.
>> THE CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO GO
INTO EVERYTHING, CALIFORNIA USED
TO BE THE STATE WHERE WE TRY TO
PUT EVERYTHING FIRST.
BUT THE LAST DECADE WE'VE BEEN
DOING EVERYTHING LAST.
WHAT I WOULD SAY TO PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, IF YOU
REALLY BELIEVE ENOUGH INTO THE
SYSTEM.
THAT'S BETTER ON PARENTS.
IN THE SCHOOL FOR THEM.
EVERYONE SHOULD GO TO FIXED
CALIFORNIA.COM, SIGN UP AND HELP
US FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
THAT PARENTS UNDER A YEAR END
HALF OF ZOOM SCHOOL WANT TO HAVE
THE POWER TO PICK THE SCHOOL FOR
THE KIDS.
LET'S LET THE PARENTS GIVE THEM
THE TOOLS THEY NEED.
LET'S NOT HAVE THE WEALTHY KIDS
GOING TO PRIVATE SCHOOL OR PICK.
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PICK
THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS OF THEM ARE
REALLY GOOD PUBLIC SCHOOL.
LET'S GIVE THE POWER TO THE
PARENTS NOT JUST THE RICH
PARENTS.
STEVE: IT'S AN INSPIRING
MESSAGE.
SO FANTASTIC THAT BOTH OF YOU
COME TOGETHER TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
EVERYONE SHOULD GO TO FIXED